elisabeth Lévy Philippe Bilger Louis
Morin Philippe Guibert je compte sur
vous ce matin pour dire des choses qui
n'ont pas été dites ailleurs autrement
ça n'a pas d'intérêt essayez de dire des
choses intelligentes
des choses un peu je compte sur vous
c'est pour ça que vous êtes là regardez
attention c'est parti c'est bluffant hop
l'estimation des résultats on a
l'abstention qui est juste ici hop là
j'en étais où oui donc demain 36 à
Marseille c'est quand même très très
chaud Patrick je t'avais dit de fermer
les onglets merci au revoir voilà gênant
regardez là c'est vraiment gros coup sur
coup Philippot venait et lalal on
attendait tous ces résultats là
et c'est là qu'on se rend compte de
l'influence de Bill Gates et de Big
Pharma et du lobby de la 5G sur les
législatives françaises comme par hasard
c'est eux qui perdent c'est louche c'est
louche à regarder l'attacher de près on
comprend que ça ne sent pas bon mais
rien n'est encore joué 20h les résultats
nationaux sont annoncés qui arrive en
tête
1% des voix un candidat pour la
rassemblement ceux qui voulaient l'Union
des droites se font doubler par une
union des gauches
[Musique]
Jean-Luc Mélenchon avec la moustache
voilà il a 30 ans on est à Massy à ce
moment-là d'ailleurs pour la petite
histoire israélus sénateur dans cette
circonscription 5 ans plus tard et c'est
sa première apparition télé qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé en fait c'est la
moustache
il a été relooké après un certain temps
c'est vrai Nathalie on est pas loin
et on a Ervin qui est avec nous du côté
de Nantes bonjour Irvine bonjour
bienvenue ouvriez viticole mon chéri
alors qui a gagné ce soir enfin ce matin
je lance en appel à témoin tout de suite
si vous êtes l'un de ces candidats qui
hier a récolter 0 % soit 0 voix hier
leur nom s'affiche ce sont de vrais noms
et qui n'a donc même pas voté pour
lui-même contactez-nous on aimerait
comprendre le concept d'avance merci
quel ingrédient manque trois fois à
cette préparation
inefficace vendue en poudre indice
Antoine
oh là là dis donc Brian et la France
tout va bien c'est la poudre de
perlimpinpin c'est ça quelques semaines
avant les Législatives Emmanuel Macron
était parti se ressourcer au Fort de
Brégançon une des résidences
présidentielles dans le sud de la France
parfait si le chef de l'État a été pas
paradisé par voici au côté de Brigitte
l'article a dévoilé une autre photo
accompagnée de la légende ces gardes du
corps sont allés repêcher la baballe du
chien en effet sur le cliché on peut y
voir deux hommes à l'eau alors que Nemo
le chien d'Emmanuel Macron préfère ne
pas se mouiller étonnant quand on porte
un tel nom chien comportement totalement
inhabituel Francis Lalanne le pire
2,13% des voix c'est officiel Francis
Lalanne a plus de voix dans sa tête
qu'aux élections législatives et encore
deux infos la première le tweet du fils
d'Anne Hidalgo je sais pas si on avait
passé Arthur Germain qui a mis en scène
son abstention très fière de lui il a
jeté son bulletin de vote à la poubelle
à vidalgo elle était déjà pour
l'avortement à mon avis depuis hier elle
est pour l'avortement jusqu'au 32 ans
c'est pas la bonne poubelle et en plus
Arthur Germain vous avez peut-être vu ce
tweet d'Arthur Germain qui est le fils
d'Anne Hidalgo donc lui il a mis son
bulletin à la poubelle il a l'air
vraiment intelligence Arthur Germain
vraiment c'est je le connais pas mais
c'est vraiment
il n'a pas voté législatif 2022 quand
changer les règles du jeu ne suffit plus
c'est le jeu qu'il faut changer donc et
puis il s'est mis en scène avec cette
aire intéressant qu'il a sur cette photo
Arthur Germain le fils de vote pas alors
on va voir qui passait son temps dans
les bistrots pendant ses études ou pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ou quoi
là ça sent vraiment le cramé